with homeless be in there is that one
um
bin man ill prostitute or something like
that sell an ass on the street
okay so you see what the audience said
yeah yeah okay
Batman
hello there my name is Lewis Capaldi and
today I'm going to be finding out what
the lad Babel audience thinks of me
which of these dates would be Los
capali's ideal first date a
New Leaf drying I've done that before
yeah
Netflix and chill does that just mean
sex yeah okay
fun good fun a lot of good fun Glasgow
open top bus tour
um
I would probably say
Late Night karaoke I think okay I like
karaoke I'm a big fan past there I'm
singing everybody else is singing but
you don't pick a song that you're good
at singing because it's like if somebody
gets something they're good it's like
yeah I like to sing to all the clips of
the Heart by Bonnie Tyler
um but because it's so high
so when I'm trying to sing it it's
finally I'm deafening people when it
sounds incredible and I think that's
maybe the best way to go about things
okay
let's have a look
New Life drawing 32 percent
I have so I did draw this guy massive
[ __ ] on a huge penis me and it was Roman
Kemp of capital breakfast theme and you
know came out on camps bowl back and I
guess I shall lick it was a vagina as
well that makes mum and dad that's good
um nude life drop should be dead we drew
a man a man's big massive
dangly Hogg for um okay it was lovely
though it was uh really it was a yummy
looking piece let's put it that way and
which of these pictures does look how
they look the sexiest
I think it's got to be the sexy cowboy
um just uh sleeveless sleeveless those
pants didn't actually
um button up
um that was good it was called that
little cockatiel Dundee that was me okay
okay here we go
wow
40 of of B which is I don't know fans
are like I suppose it is like Lads so
it's like everybody who loves us Liam
Gallagher and the rest of like bucket
hats most of the people who voted on it
probably looks like that exactly
so uh I'm surprised I'm surprised but
then D was second yeah seriously yeah I
mean so um
wasn't a singer which job would he do I
don't think they're going to be model
I don't think it's gonna and these are
going to be very favorable with homeless
be in there is that one
perhaps
um
bin man I don't know like a
you know prostitute or something like
that
selling ass on the street
okay so you see what the audience said
okay
Batman
that's cool I mean it's terrible for my
self-esteem but I mean not that being a
Batman's a bad job I've dug myself
um that was good five percent I was
expecting more I mean if that's 33 I
don't expect that the rest of them to be
and favorable okay
number two is gonna be like dinner later
somewhere
McDonald's welcome McDonald's okay
I can handle that a few years before
kind of my music was going well my
brother for Christmas had went to the
trouble of rapping a McDonald's
application form for me because I didn't
have a job and he thought it would be
funny right six percent
comedian that's good that's nice yeah
yeah now I feel Under Pressure to be
making jokes and stuff but that's really
nice and I think if you put me up
against any other proper
um I think like an actual comedian you
would say that that's what is Lewis's
favorite swear words got to be it's got
to be
here we go number three
sorry that was just like
it's number two wow surprising surprise
surprise what's up there too what do you
like about coffee and yeah oh yeah
um I just think it's not because in
Scotland it's not well in the UK it's
not as bad of a world like he's suddenly
making a good on a like he's a sound and
I'd like it when you go to America and
you see it and people are like like
you've just shot them like like you
don't mean shagged them or something I
don't know but like it's just so class
that they're like they're just like saw
aghast that you say that and then like
just to continue seeing it and seeing
how uncomfortable they get when you see
it at class I would never say it
referring to a woman's vagina
I think that's disgusting
if you're saying like
oh a ladies
that's gross but if you're saying like
oh he's a he's a good whatever are you
doing I think
that's lovely that's fine sorry for the
editors yeah I'm taking this out but
it's all good okay well they have to be
perfect yeah all right
Lewis was in a boy band which one of
these would you be in a
Westland
B One Direction
see take that
D BTS
I don't think I'm going to be in a K-pop
man I'd love to be in BTS yeah how did
in the BTS Army on Twitter was like you
in the band and I think they would take
it well I think they would enjoy me
joining a band especially at this
juncture who did it in the audience said
I don't think they picked BTS
I think the potentially packed it's got
I would say One Direction okay
for close enough in ages
Zayn left
Liam Payne's doing some really weird
yeah I'd say I'll See You One Direction
okay let's see what this is
Westlife
all right okay
I definitely have a view of myself that
other people don't have so which one
would you want to be in wondering
right now I'll just end your handle just
at any time BTS
BTS but I think they're pretty huge
and people really love them what
question is Louis Capaldi most tired of
being asked the most commonly asked
question
on if you Google lose Capaldi which I
have because I'm a
[Music]
um as what disease does Lewis Capaldi
have
so so he's there that's yeah should we
see what disease I have come on let's go
what do you think of the Gallagher seven
percent
um yeah I don't
I don't I don't really get asked that
much often I just asked about like Noel
and all that [ __ ] um I love both of them
is the answer have you ever considered
being obedient I don't really get tired
of being asked that are you dating
anyone right now will no one asks me
that weirdly I don't get asked as much
as like a Harry Styles or like uh or
like
for anyone in a boy band and it's like I
didn't really get asked that I think
people just assume that I'm not seeing
anybody
um ever so yeah that's not really one
are you Scottish I don't think anyone's
ever asked me if I'm Scottish I think
people was pretty clear none of these
annoy me really I wish people ask me if
I was dating anyone let me know and more
often that the answer's giving up what
TV show would you most like to see Lewis
Capaldi on top three answers it's got to
beasts I'm a celebrity it's got to be
number one kangaroo knobs and bum holes
and my gob right number three task mask
stuff that's the one where they're
giving tasks yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
like that show Greg Davies does it yeah
correct like him I would love to do it
if he would have me nice one number two
love Island
I thought that meant creep up and then
when you first walk out and everyone's
like back to bed so I don't think me Al
definitely wearing a t-shirt t-shirt on
in the pool wouldn't that like people
like I don't think that's gonna be uh
what anybody wants to see gogglebox not
what I thought it was going to be that'd
be lovely it'd be great fun although I
don't think I don't know how people get
away with like not like really slagging
people off on the toilet because I think
that's just the whole week do on my
house
um what would you like to be on I'd like
to do I would like to do gogglebox
that'd be fun
um it would be your partner on it my
partner on it would be someone like
and
who could possibly be
me
um
[Music]
David Attenborough Maine that being by
Dave not like David probably go on it
and just
mash it up what do you think Lewis
Capaldi has been up to all this time you
would hope the answer is writing an
album doing his job and just a power of
shagging wouldn't be a good one as well
but I would pick oh untrue okay let's do
the answers number three don't care
great
that's good that's really really good
nice to know that people have missed me
drinking too I did do quite a bit of
drinking over lockdown number four
that's lovely top one rating new music
lovely stuff
what real reality TV show would you most
like to see Liam in like it's got to be
the jungle on it God I'd really love to
see me in that squirming eating frogs
balls and [ __ ] you know what I mean